vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Rosa Pérez mas deu Rosa un buen día para
usted Hola Ángela Buenos días bien vamos
a empezar a esta sección dedicándonos a
las novedades de la guerra en Ucrania
empezamos con el ataque a la presa de
Nova jacobca que ha estado en nuestros
titulares y seguro lo estará durante
todo el día hay información confusa qué
nos dice la prensa de Ucrania sí Ángela
hay información muy Cruzada una vez más
digamos que la guerra se traslada al
campo de la información y lo que está
pasando Es que como bien decías en los
propios noticieros lo estábamos
explicando cada uno de los mandos acusa
al otro de haber provocado este ataque
primero de hecho si te parece un apunte
para nuestra audiencia porque siempre es
confuso imaginar el mapa de Cómo se
desarrolla la guerra recordemos que esta
presa no que ha estallado se encuentra
en el río nieper que atraviesa la región
de gersón gersón recordemos es una de
las regiones que fue anexionada
unilateralmente por Rusia en septiembre
de 2022 Sin embargo las rusas no
controlan toda la región sino que
controlan solamente una parte y de hecho
este río donde se encuentra la presa
funciona a la práctica como frente
natural de la guerra por lo que las
fuerzas ucranianas están a la orilla
oeste de este río y las fuerzas rusas a
la orilla este por lo tanto la explosión
la digamos el incidente al final afecta
a ambos bandos no porque el
desbordamiento del río pues afecta a las
dos orillas de hecho las preocupaciones
por este desbordamiento van tanto por lo
que son inundaciones es decir exceso de
agua y las afectaciones que puedan tener
a la población Y al medio ambiente
también por escasez de agua y esto es lo
que denuncian también ambas partes y es
que este río enfría no la central
nuclear de saporía por lo que si hay
escasez en este suministro esto podría
suponer un problema y también hace
llegar agua a la Península de crimea que
recordemos fue anexionada también
unilateralmente por Rusia en 2014 bien
después de estos apuntes como bien
decías la prensa ucraniana da por hecho
que este ataque ha sido un ataque ruso
de hecho el jefe independen dice las
fuerzas rusas destruyen la presa de
cacoba Desatando un desastre humanitario
no bien a partir de aquí como decíamos
el alcalde exiliado de Nueva cacova el
alcalde ucraniano que ya no vive ahí
porque esa ciudad está ocupada por las
fuerzas rusas dice también han volado la
sala de máquinas de la central
hidroeléctrica de la presa Mientras que
el Gobernador prorruso señala que fueron
bombardeos ucranianos Y en este artículo
del que independent citan a un vecino
que dice se derrumbó toda la presa como
un castillo de naipes una imagen
bastante gráfica no también citan
recuerdan una cita desde lensky 2022 que
decía que Rusia Sí atacaba esta empresa
como finalmente ha pasado sea quien sea
la autoría de los hechos estaría
declarando la guerra al mundo entero
bien en fin y después el postró medio
ucraniano dice Recuerda que kiev ha
denunciado este ataque ante la Corte
Internacional de Justicia como un crimen
de guerra Pues los aquí dice la prensa
rusa como decíamos la prensa rusa todo
lo contrario da por hecho que este
ataque provino de las fuerzas ucranianas
empezamos por bedomory que es un medio
bastante independiente ruso que cita a
la agencia tass diciendo el ataque
contra la planta hidroeléctrica que
provocó la destrucción de la presa fue
infligido supuestamente por las fuerzas
armadas de Ucrania con el sistema de
cohetes de lanzamiento múltiple alder
Bien también señalan que la presa no se
puede reparar y citan al gobernador
proruso de la región que dice habrá que
reconstruirla tras la victoria rusa
evidentemente se entiende y citan
también a un experto militar yuric
nuttorf que dice todo apunta a que se
trata de una explosión deliberada
después de la destrucción de la presa
aumentó La amenaza de desembarco de
tropas ucranianas a través del río
nieper a territorio controlado por Rusia
no Esta es pues la versión rusa que
digamos estaría la estaría el ejército
ucraniano aprovechando estas
inundaciones y esta distracción para
cruzar a la orilla este del río nieper
que está controlada por las fuerzas
rusas RT dice el nivel de agua en el río
nieper ha aumentado más de 10 metros en
el área de novakova en la región rusa de
gerson después de que un ataque
ucraniano dañara gravemente la principal
Represa local bien sin embargo RT cita
también la versión de kiev diciendo kiev
niega la responsabilidad y acusa a Moscú
de crear el mayor desastre ambiental en
Europa en décadas
el tema La verdad es que ha trascendido
prácticamente a todos los medios de
comunicación que siguen la guerra que
son todos Sí exactamente Entonces los
medios que tienen una sección
internacional siguen el día a día de
esta guerra en Ucrania y el músculo
Times cita en este caso a dimitripes el
portavoz del kremlin que ya ha hablado
de un Sabotaje deliberado por parte de
Ucrania y dice que
está este ataque ucraniano respondería a
las pérdidas a tempranas que han tenido
en sus primeros días de contraofensiva y
señaló
debe asumir toda la responsabilidad de
las graves consecuencias que tiene este
este incidente para el medio ambiente y
para las personas después lo mondi ha
ido recogiendo un poco las reacciones
internacionales a estos hechos por un
lado la otan denuncia la brutalidad de
Rusia el canciller Alemán dijo que este
ataque da una nueva dimensión a la
guerra Y por último nos hemos querido
centrar en uno de los apartados que
desta Lemon que es preocupación por la
central nuclear de zapolilla algo que
hemos mencionado al principio bien
recordemos que esta central está
administrada por los rusos Que de
momento dicen que no están preocupados
por la situación inmediata de la planta
nuclear la más grande de Europa la
organización internacional el organismo
Internacional de la energía atómica
también ha señalado que no hay riesgo
inmediato sin embargo kiev sí que está
encendiendo las alarmas diciendo que hay
un creciente peligro y el de hecho el
consejero de la presidencia de Ucrania
dijo el mundo se encuentra una vez más
al borde de una catástrofe nuclear
porque la central nuclear ha perdido su
fuente de refrigeración y este peligro
aumenta rápidamente bien finalmente kiev
acusa a Rusia de intentar frenar su
contraofensiva con este ataque
precisamente supuesto inicio de la
contraofensiva ocupa portadas
internacionales el día de una
contraofensiva que no está confirmada
pero
bueno es que no podemos ni siquiera
opinar sobre el tema Exactamente no como
dices Ángel está contraofensiva pues
kievfa no la confirma sin embargo ha
sido identificada por decirlo de algún
modo por Estados Unidos y por Rusia
rápidamente el país titula Ucrania pasa
el ataque y Abre una nueva fase ofensiva
contra Rusia the Times este medio
británico dice en un pie de foto tropa
ucranianas en harquis ofrecen símbolos
de desafío en lo que tanto los rusos
como los estadounidenses han descrito
como el primer día de la contraofensiva
ucraniana el Washington post Ucrania
avancia avanza hacia el Issste y el New
York Times oficiales de Estados Unidos
detectan signos de la contraofensiva de
kiev Pues bien Rosa además de esto pues
siguen habiendo movimientos alrededor de
la guerra ayer medios de comunicación de
crimea fueron supuestamente hackeados
con un falso anuncio de Vladimir Putin
de qué se trata esto Exacto rápidamente
Ángela un tema que también ha llegado a
muchos a titulares en este caso hemos
seleccionado el de South china morning
post y el de político que explican que
ayer tanto televisiones como radios de
crimea recordemos península anexionada
por Rusia o sea 1014
empezaron a transmitir un mensaje de
Vladimir Putin creado con la
Inteligencia artificial no un Deep fake
en que Vladimir Putin decía literalmente
las tropas ucranianas armadas por la
otan apoyadas por Estados Unidos han
invadido velgot kurts y brians y
anunciaba la ley Marcial la movilización
general y la evacuación de civiles en
estas tres zonas Dimitri prescott
portavoz del kremlin anunció que
efectivamente era un discurso falso que
duró unos 40 minutos este hackeo de
momento no se conocen mucho más detalles
y finalmente la bbc Recuerda que no es
la primera vez que pasa esto a lo largo
de esta guerra donde la batalla
informativa están destacable que también
circula de vez en cuando en internet un
mensaje de Vladimir Putin declarando La
Paz o uno de zelensky rindiéndose ante
Rusia pues Rosa Muchísimas gracias
completísimo informe y vamos a
complementarlo con nuestro invitado del
día exactamente Hasta mañana Ángela